hey crazies once or twice you might have
heard someone say something like there's
not really a fabric though it's just an
analogy it's meant to make space in time
sound more tangible like something that
can be changed but what if there was a
fabric how elastic would it be this
episode was made possible by generous
supporters on patreon the interaction
between space time and matter is
governed by Einstein's equation it looks
something like this
which can be a bit intimidating okay
it's a lot intimidating but all this
stuff is really just one thing
space-time curvature this other thing is
the energy in that space-time more
energy means more curvature less energy
means less curvature as John Wheeler
once said space-time tells matter how to
move and matter tells space-time how to
curve what's that have to do with the
elasticity though more than you might
think we'll set this thing aside and
come back to it later though that's been
bugging me for a job lately anyway he
could hold onto it for us oh no no no
space aliens can't take him anywhere
anyway let's talk about elasticity for a
minute we'll start with the easiest
example a spring the tension in a spring
is just a constant times how much it
stretched we call that constant the
spring stiffness because the bigger it
is the more force it takes to stretch
the spring the stiffer the spring the
less elastic it is so that constant
tells us about its elasticity which is
exactly what we're interested in this
relationship is Hookes law the force is
what we'd call an external cause for
example our spring has a weight hanging
on it that causes it to stretch the
stretch itself is what we'd call an
internal response we're all familiar
with how things respond externally
Newton's second law
she says they accelerate but things also
respond internally the ball compresses
because the back of it accelerates
before the front does other causes can
even make objects change shape an
external cause will always result in
some kind of internal response generally
we write that like this which is still
called Hookes law because that's not
confusing the response is proportional
to the cause the point is we have a
general rule for elasticity one that
applies to more than just Springs the
formal names for these two measurements
are stress and strain but I like cause
and responds better they're less jargony
just like with Springs this constant
measures how rigid the material is it's
the rigidity isn't that the opposite of
what we want mm oh you're right
let's take that constant and put it on
the other side that way the equation
takes us from the cause to the response
as it should be we'll call one over
rigidity the elasticity just to make our
lives easier I feel like I've seen a
relationship like this before right
right
Oh in science equation earlier we saw
that space-time curvature is
proportional to energy in fact that
energy is the reason space-time curves
which makes it the cause and the
curvature is the response it's the same
question that means if space-time were
some kind of material this constant
would be its elasticity and we happen to
know what that constant is it's on the
order of 10 to the minus 43 that's 43
places after the decimal point which is
very little elasticity space-time is
super rigid and that definitely makes
sense it takes the mass of something
like a planet or moon to even notice
gravity it's the weakest of the
fundamental forces because space-time is
so rigid where did that constant come
from though what do you mean I just plug
stuff fill divide I mean why is it that
number oh because it has to be
consistent with Newtonian gravity every
new model we come up with has to be
consistent with older time-tested models
say we've got two rocks floating in
space each one of them has a man
maybe one of them is bigger than the
other it doesn't matter Newton says they
each experience a force related to both
of their masses and the distance between
them which is great and all but but
forces aren't actually that useful for
deeper understanding I mean they make
intuitive sense to us it's just we found
that writing laws in terms of energy
instead makes them look less ugly to the
timeline Newton's law of gravity was
developed in the 1660s
but in 1813 Samiha plus one
Simeon Samia Samia Samia plus one Wausau
Wausau semi-auto song came up with an
equation we now call poissons equation
which transforms Newton's force law into
an energy law granted it wasn't called
energy back then but that's what it was
whether it was called that or not
basically this says a change in energy
across space is caused by a mass
actually that's not energy that's the
energy per unit mass or potential also
that's not mass its mass density it
doesn't matter if we're only looking at
this conceptually this is energy
adjacent and this is mass adjacent it's
close enough
aiyaaa if we map out those energy values
across space near something like the
earth it looks like this it's a bunch of
negative numbers the earth is creating
something we call a gravitational well
but if we're going to call it a well we
might as well imagine it as one did you
catch that we might as well cuz it's a
gravitational well such a torque let's
imagine that each of these numbers
represents the depth of the well at that
location in that case we'd have
something that looks like this which
should look familiar it's that one
graphic you usually see when someone's
talking about curved space-time except I
just made it without using Einstein's
equation it's made using poissons
equation an equation based on your Toni
and gravity bubbles burst it to be fair
though that gravitational well does look
kind
like a fabric almost like poissons
equation is only one step away from
Einsteins in fact Einstein's equation is
also an energy equation every term in
here is also energy adjacent so under
the right conditions it should simplify
to Poisson equation and that's exactly
what happens we call it the weak field
limit in which we make two assumptions
one the cause of the curvature is an
object made of matter and the particles
in that object are moving slow compared
to light to the curvature is very close
to zero it's pretty much just the
space-time from special relativity plus
a smidge of curvature just a smidge
though both of these assumptions are
perfectly reasonable around something
like the earth where we'd expect
Newton's law of gravity to apply in the
weak field limit Einstein's equation
looks like this
which is only a constant factor away
from Poisson equation it's the same
equation at least in the weak field
limit of course the fabric analogy is
just that in analogy and all analogies
have problems for one real life
materials don't always have our
proportional response
if you stretch them too much they can
permanently deform or even break space
times response is always proportional
that might make you think that
space-time is simpler but it's just
complicated in other ways for example
I've been displaying it as a two
dimensional surface because that's easy
but that's a terribly inaccurate visual
space-time isn't two dimensional it's
four dimensional both the cause and the
response are represented by four
dimensional tensors each with ten unique
components the weak field limit only
uses one of them most of the gravity
humans experience on earth isn't even
space curvature its time curvature so
how elastic is the fabric of the
universe not very elastic at all
actually
it's on the order of 10 to the minus 43
it takes a ridiculous amount of matter
or light in one place to even notice
gravity space-time might not actually be
a fabric
whatever it is it's pretty rigid stuff
so how many of your bubbles did I burst
today please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to Nicholas
Vassalo glue fest Vassalo glue Vassalo
glue for being one of our new orderlies
on patreon if you can help out even one
dollar a month on patreon gets you
access to our monthly live Q&A YouTube
channel members have access to don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
to everyone complaining about how I
ignored air resistance in my earth
tunnel of course I did do you think I'd
go through the trouble of drilling a
hole all the way through the earth and
then not evacuate the air
come on crazies anyway thanks for
watching